I'm very excited to meet you.
Yeah, thanks for having us.
Yeah, thank you.
Michael, will you tell us what happened?
Yeah, we were on our way back
from a mass vaccination clinic
that we actually had to shut down early
because of severe weather.
And we apparently didn't get out quite early enough,
because we wound up being stuck on a mountain top
because a snow storm and a jackknifed trailer.
So we had six doses left over,
that we couldn't use before we ran out the door
and we had people lined up to get 'em
but we just couldn't get to 'em in time.
So we had to make the decision in the moment
and we decided it was better to use them then and there,
on the side of the road
than it was to let 'em go to waste.
And Michael and Leah, really quickly,
what was that conversation like?
You're like, "okay, let's just find arms and people,
and tell our story and get this done
and not waste these precious vaccines."
What, what, what, what do you say?
It was interesting having those conversations.
Internally, the first thing we asked was, is this safe?
We had a doctor on staff.
We had an ambulance with us at the time.
And as soon as we got the thumbs up from them,
I said, okay, let's go.
And we all zipped up our coats
and started walking through the snow.
And Leah you were actually the one
administering the vaccine.
What was that like?
Oh, we had a pretty wide spectrum of reactions.
This part of the country, there's some vaccine hesitancy.
So most people just politely declined, but of course,
six people were excited about it.
And we were able to give those six people vaccines.
Among them was this guy that was like so ecstatic.
He jumped out of his car practically
and ripped off his shirt.
We also had a Deputy Sheriff from our county
who was trying to come to the mass vaccination event
to get her vaccine, but she was too late, she missed it.
And so we were able to give her a vaccine, too.
Well, I am really, really, really grateful
that you were able to spring into action.
I'm so beyond impressed with you guys
and I know everybody else is, too.
And thank you for your service.
(upbeat music)